now testing clinics seeing a high number
of people looking to find out if they
have covid19 or not mary jane baliza is
live at unlv a popular testing location
but earlier today mary jane you found
other locations to help get you some
answers
yeah that's absolutely right brian i
mean this testing location behind me
opened up at just 5 30 and people were
waiting well before they evened open now
operations resumed here on sunday and
run through thursday according to the
health district there are other
locations throughout the valley and
making an appointment is the best way to
beat the rush
it's really hard to get a place to find
every place
we went to the one down on decatur we
were in a long line there
the staff had left and nobody told
anybody outside
so then i started looking for a place
that was open later lanny breithout and
rietta ellis want to get tested ahead of
the new year with appointments booked
solid covet testing sites like famatech
have seen a surge operations manager
angela spears expects more people to get
tested after the new year's weekend
we've been quite busy you know but our
system is pretty efficient
fast in and out famatech located on
eastern and twain offers both rt pcr
testing and rapid antigen testing for
those looking for quick results my
turnaround times for our tpcr test is 24
24 to 30 hours give or take and our
rapid antigens is about 15 to 30 minutes
i spoke to dr court loaf with the health
district he says while there is plenty
of testing capacity available expect
long wait times in addition to the
increase in demand for testing we are
seeing an uptick in a number of cases as
well as in our positivity rate likely
that's being fueled by the omicron
variant because this variant is much
more transmissible so none of that is a
surprise and we're seeing that around
the country as well
now dr loaf is encouraging testing if
you believe you were exposed to covet or
have any symptoms and if you do test
positive for covet 19 the cdc is
recommending you must isolate for five
days reporting here at unlv mary jane
balleza live local now